i turn around and i i say
he's just like
and i'm going how's that he's going
so so but that's what you want to do you
that's that's the job you want to pin
your director in a seat you it's not
our job as composers isn't to do what
they tell you to do our job is to
surprise them our job is to do
the stuff they can't imagine we're going
to dive straight in with rain man
because really rain man was the film
that launched you uh as internationally
wasn't it where were you and what were
you doing before you got
to rayman or when you got rain man i
know i did a film called a world apart
and
it's a it's a great movie it's actually
a wonderful movie which
um
very few people saw but diana levinson
barry levinson's wife saw it and
you know i'm always being very precise
about this story because she went into
hmv and bought him the cd and he was
over here
um promoting good morning vietnam and he
didn't have my phone number but he
somebody gave him the address for our
studio down the lily road
and 11 o'clock at night you know there's
a knock on the door and
i'm
opening a door there's a guy standing
there and he's going
hi my name is barry levinson pause
i'm a director and i'm
thinking yeah you and my mom both right
but i see behind him that these two
remember those old bentley limousines
that nobody ever drove so there were two
of those squashed down our little alley
i thought maybe he is
um and so so actually
quite recently i asked barry if he ever
saw world apart he never saw the film
but he just loved the music and he said
did i want to come to hollywood and he
was actually really worried that i would
say no and to be some sort of european
art snob as opposed to a complete [ __ ]
it turns out
so what was the brief for rain man how
did you approach it
but actually the brief was really simple
we
i've done that on a few movies
as we made a list of what not to do you
know because it's basically a road movie
and road movies in those days was either
draglee guitars or sweeping strings so
we weren't going to do jangly guitars or
sweeping strings and i just thought it
was interesting that this character was
sort of
so disoriented in the world so that the
music could be just this mashup of cuban
rhythms with crazies and sounds and
you know whatever you know it's it's
foreign foreign was good you know and
and i can get really foreign
i had a little quote from that ridley
said about you said in my head i listen
to hans's music and i don't even have to
shut my eyes i can see the pictures he
responds to pictures now we're moving
towards gladiator to talk about
gladiator how did the relationship work
let's say the difference between working
with tony scott and with ridley scott
well
the difference is that
with tony it was literally just
the most fabulous creative chaos i mean
okay so here's the difference
tony would say to me have you ever
ridden on a motorbike through the desert
at night i'm going i don't ride
motorbikes because no you've got to come
along gotta listen to the desert at
night that would be his way of
explaining something
really would phone me at nine o'clock in
the morning because he knows i'm still
asleep and
he'd go
hey do you wanna do a gladiator movie
and i'd start laughing and go what men
in skirts he'd go no it's not that sort
of a gladiator movie
and the pictures thing is very important
because
i
i learned actually on gladiator never to
don't read the script don't read the
script on a ridley scott film
go to dinner with me and get him to tell
you the story because then you figure
out what what's important for him
and because he's such an amazing artist
he inevitably at a certain point will
take the pen out and start drawing the
scenes for you so
um
you get to see the movie unfold before
your eyes because the way he draws is
the way he will shoot the scene
so
not not so bad i mean he went to he went
to the royal academy um
[Music]
you know he
from up north you know it was him and
and there was like this other
northern trap there but
everybody else was like rich and dressed
in
purple velvet and stuff like this um
and so he was the other guy was sort of
earning a bit of money on the side you
know washing up beer mugs etc but one
day brittany looked over his shoulder
and
realized that he needed to he he really
was never going to be the painter this
guy was named david hockney and that's
really what persuaded ridley that he had
to go and look broaden his gate and look
somewhere else what's interesting about
gladiator of course is it it's a fairly
traditional
traditionally scored film isn't it with
big orchestra
um i know there's other elements within
it and of course we must talk about lisa
gerard as a very important vocal element
in it but it actually it's a fairly
traditional score in in that sense
it's traditional it's a bit of a mess i
mean um
i could
again you know like like rain man
gladiator the cutting room and my studio
they cut in my studio which made it
really
collaborative and very interactive but
very early on
we had this conversation that there was
absolutely no female soul in the movie
um
i remember pietro had the
pietro scalia the editor he had three
cds standing on his little
desk and he picked the first one up and
he went you know what about lisa gerard
and
um
ridley and i just went yeah that's okay
you know sounds like a good idea and i
found it it's a too long a story to tell
you but um
that whole opening i mean obviously that
does not exist in the script because
what what would be the first thing you
would cut for budget one minute of and
it's not even russell's hand an extra's
hand on on the wheat oh you've totally
spoiled it
he doesn't i can go do you want me to do
worse you know like at the end
when he dies and he goes through elysium
skates
ridley had that image in his head he
knew he had seen the gates to heaven
somewhere and he thought it was in
tuscany so he said the scouts aren't a
tuscany wasn't there he thought it was
in spain it wasn't in spain he thought
might have been because we shot a lot of
it down in farnham you know just by
guildford yeah uh he thought i was there
and then finally he remembered it's the
cruise toilet in malta
all right so the gates to heaven did i
did i now ruin this for you for good
totally okay good
i didn't know about the battle set i
always think of that when you're going
down that big a road uh out of surrey
right just to the right i think is where
the whole of the battle scene was done
at the beginning of the film isn't it
yeah no and and you know that like like
that really big guy who holds up the
head and he's shouting something i could
and which he says he's he's the german i
said i can't understand what was he
saying
and finally when he said well he's a
scottish actor and then i understood it
he's going schweiner hunter but with a
scottish accent
the hardest thing was i had written this
crazy you know the battle stuff and that
was incredibly complex and every time
the cut
changed
pietro very kindly cut in four bar
chunks so
i could sort of go
and figure it out but um no that's great
isn't it because that doesn't always
happen though well but it's just that's
how we're supposed to be doing this
stuff together you know it's supposed to
be collaborative but there's going to be
lots of people here who don't have that
experience at all but but but the the
only thing that stops you from having
experience as well in this case
make sure you have some decent red wine
around and no you just just invite
invite your collaborators in
you know and they invite you in i mean
i think one of the advantages i have is
that i don't have a formal musical
education so i'm never gonna fall prey
to using words that are incomprehensible
to a director like allegro or
you know
you know actually yeah
chris nolan always like made a thing of
on each movie learning a new musical
term that he could sort of casually drop
in on the dumb station
so
no but i mean it's it's
it's story we're talking about story how
we're gonna tell the story i mean the
way we worked was i was literally in my
room
couch behind me ridley sitting there
smoking big cigars me going he's ruining
her voice um
lisa with a microphone the picture up
and we just we just try things up
against the picture and
i remember
the scene you know where russell comes
home and finds that his wife has been
killed
and we had thought we'd done something
like extraordinary and we played it
directly no that's not really working
for me and so this turned into this
whole conversation like at two o'clock
in the morning after she was poisoned by
more cigar smoke than you can imagine um
lisa went okay fine i'm gonna have one
more go and you know
she's pretty
wound up at that point
and
i we just put the scene up you know meet
me playing to it and you know and she
just laid into it you know
and it was the most amazing performance
i mean it came from
it came from a place that you know
it's just an extraordinary place but i'm
not sure you want to go and know where
that place is somehow it's like it was
so dark
yeah and
and i turned around and i just i said
he's just like
okay how's that he's going
[Laughter]
so but that's what you want to do you
that's that's the job you want to pin
your director in a seat you it's not
our job as composers isn't to do what
they tell you to do our job is to
surprise them our job is to do
the stuff they can't imagine
you know
that's you know and if you work with
great directors they love that you know
never thought about it that way that's
the best compliment you can get
[Music]
[Music]
you